i have to ask you about the wizard hat
you wrote a blog about neurolink i got a
chance to visit you like a couple of
times hanging out with those folks
um
you're that was one of the pieces of
writing you did that like
changes culture and changes the way
people think about a thing
the ridiculousness of your stick figure
drawings are somehow um
it's like you know it's like
calling the origin of the universe the
big bang it's a slowly titled but it
somehow sticks to be the representative
of uh
of that the same way the wizard had for
the new link is um
somehow it was a really powerful way to
to explain that you actually proposed
that the the man of the year cover of
time should be um one of my drawings why
are your drawings yes yes there's an
outrage that it was it was
okay
so
uh what are your thoughts about like all
those years later about your link
do you find this idea like what excites
you about is the big long term
philosophical things is it the the
practical things do you think is super
difficult to do on the neurosurgery side
and the material engineering the
robotics side
or do you think um the machine learning
side for the brain computer interfaces
where they get to learn about each other
all that kind of stuff i'll just love to
get your thoughts because you're one of
the people that
really considered this problem really
studied it okay on computer interfaces i
mean i'm super excited about it um it's
a
i really think it's actually elon's most
ambitious thing
more than colonizing mars because that's
just a bunch of people going somewhere
even though it's somewhere far
neuralink is changing what a person is
um eventually now
i i think that neuralink
engineers and elon himself would all be
the first to admit that it is a maybe
that when they whether they can do their
goals here i mean it is so crazy
ambitious to try to you know their
eventual goals are you know of course in
the in the interim they have a higher
probability of accomplishing smaller
things which are still huge like
basically solving paralysis
uh you know strokes parkinson things
like that i mean it can be unbelievable
and you know
anyone who doesn't have one of these
things like we might you know everyone
should be very happy about um
this kind of um helping with different
disabilities
um
but the thing that is like so
the grand goal is this augmentation
where it's you take someone who's
totally healthy and you put a
pre-machine interface in any way to give
them super powers
um i you know it's the the possibilities
that they can do this if they can really
so you know they've already shown that
they are for real with you know they've
created this robot
elon talks about like it should be like
lasik where it's not
it shouldn't be something that needs a
surgeon this shouldn't just be for
rich people who have waited in line for
six months it should be for anyone who
can afford lasik and eventually
hopefully something that isn't covered
by
insurance so you know something that
anyone can do um something this big a
deal should be something that anyone can
afford eventually
and
when we have this again i'm talking
about a very advanced phase down the
road so maybe a less advanced phase just
to just there
maybe right now uh if you think about
when you listen to a mute when you
listen to a song what's happening
is do you actually hear the sound well
not really it's that the sound
is coming out of the speaker the speaker
is vibrating it's vibrating air
molecules those air molecules you know
get vibrated all the way to your head um
uh the pressure wave and then
it vibrates your eardrum your eardrum is
really the speaker now in your head
that then vibrates bones and fluid which
then
stimulates neurons in your auditory
cortex which
give you the perception that you're
hearing sound
now if you think about that
do we really need to have a speaker to
do that
you could just somehow if you had a
little tiny thing that could vibrate ear
drums you could do it that way that
seems very hard but really what you need
if you go to the very end with the thing
that really needs to happen is your
auditory cortex neurons need to be
stimulated in a certain way
if you have a ton of knurling things in
their neurolink electrodes and then
they'll get really good at stimulating
things you could play a song in your
head that you hear that not is not
playing anywhere there's no sound in the
room but you hear it and no one else
could it's not like they can get close
to your head and hear it there's no
sound they could not hear anything but
you hear sound you can turn up so you
open your phone you have the neural link
app you open the knurling gap you know
and and or just know so so basically you
can open your spotify and you can play
to you know your you can play to your
speaker you can play to your computer
you can play right out of your phone to
your headphones or
you can you now have a new one you can
play into your brain and this is uh one
of the earlier things this is you know
something that seems like really doable
um so
you know no more headphones i always
think it's so annoying because i can
leave the house with just my phone
you know and nothing else or even just
an apple watch there's always this one
thing like and headphones you do need
your headphones right so i feel like you
know that'll be the end of that but
there's so many things that you and you
keep going
the ability to think together you know
you can talk about like super brains i
mean
one of the examples elon uses is that
the low bandwidth of speech
um if i go to a movie
and i and i come out of a scary movie
and you say how was this oh it was
terrifying well
what did i just do i just gave you a i
just gave you i had five buckets i could
have given you one was horrifying
terrifying scary eerie creepy whatever
that's about it
and
i had a much more nuanced experience
than that
and i don't all i have is you know these
these words right and so instead i just
hand you the bucket
i put the stuff in the head in the
bucket and give it to you but all you
have is the bucket you just have to
guess what what i put into that bucket
all you can do is look at the label of
the bucket and say i'll us when i say
terrifying here's what i mean so the
point is it's very lossy i had this all
this nuanced information of what i
thought of the movie and i'm sending you
a very low res package that you're going
to now guess what the high-res thing
looked like
that's language in general our thoughts
are much more nuanced if we can think to
each other we can do amazing things we
could a have a brainstorm that doesn't
feel like oh we're not talking in each
other's head it's not just that i hear
your voice no no we are just thinking no
no words are being said internally or
externally
the two brains are literally
collaborating it's something it's a
skill i'm sure we'd have to get good at
it i'm sure young kids will be great at
it and old people will be bad yeah but
you think together and together you're
like have they joined epiphany and now
how about eight people in a room doing
it right so it gets you know there's
other examples how about when you're a
dress designer or a bridge designer and
you you want to
show people what your dress looks like
well right now you've got to sketch it
for a long time here just beam it onto
the screen from your head so you can
picture it if you know if you can
picture a tree in your head well you can
just suddenly whatever's in your head
you can be pictured so we'll have to get
very good at it right and take a skill
right you know you're gonna have to but
the possibilities my god talk about like
i feel like if that works if we really
do have that uh as something i think
it'll almost be like a new adbc line
it's such a big change that the idea of
like anyone living before everyone had
brain machine interfaces is living in
like before the common era it's that
level of like big change if it can work
you